[Musique]
avez vous déjà fait l'expérience d'une
réussite qui vous a semblé vous paraît
complètement naturel vous savez ce
sentiment étrange et délicieux d'être
arrivé au résultat auquel vous êtes
arrivé sans forcer parfois même sans le
vouloir
c'est magique n'est ce pas j'ai
découvert le snowboard
quand j'avais 16 ans ça a marqué le
début d'une réaction en chaîne de
passion incroyable qui m'a mené à
découvrir la street luge six ans plus
tard et à travers cette pratique a
connecté à vivre et à comprendre à ces
moments magiques
la streak lui c'est ça et en blanc
devant c'est moi nous descendons
allonger les pieds devant des routes
vallonnées fermée à la circulation
sécurisée avec des bottes de paille
défilé des matelas tout le vocabulaire
que vous pouvez imaginer associés aux
sports de glisse aux sports extrêmes s'y
retrouve l'intensité la vitesse
l'adrénaline le fun et le risque il
s'est très vite avéré que j'avais un
plaisir énorme à faire de la luge
également du buzz board qui est une
autre discipline plus petites plus
maniable plus joueuse et j'avais
également certaine facilité
ça m'a mené à être championne du monde
championne d'europe quatre ou cinq fois
championne de france en catégorie femmes
et à chaque fois dans les deux
disciplines est également là où c'est
devenu encore plus intéressant c'est
quand j'ai commencé à faire des
résultats en catégorie open avec les
hommes donc j'ai accumulé avec les
années les places d'honneur avec des
fois une incartade sur un podium mais
vous savez quoi
il ya une chose dont j'aimerais vous
parler aujourd'hui c'est ce rapport à la
compétition et à la performance
parce que toujours lorsque j'étais sur
des événements il y avait un
je-ne-sais-quoi qui me plaisait moyens
ce que vous savez quoi
la compétition s'est pas du tout ma
tasse de thé mais alors pas du tout j'ai
toujours vu comme un billet pour accéder
à des routes absolument incroyable que
javel du coup là
chance de rouler fermée à la circulation
et sécuriser avec mes amis et d'une
manière générale passé du temps vraiment
de qualité avec la communauté
internationale ou nationale
la compétition en soi a toujours été un
prix à payer
jamais une fin en soi étonnant pour
quelqu'un qui a un qui a mais mes titres
je dis regardez cette photo
regardez ma tête je suis en pleine
décomposition je suis un peu le position
en finale des championnats de france de
descente un buzz board donc ces petits
engins plus maniable dont je vous
parlais et au vu de mes résultats sur
les tours précédents
j'ai de fortes chances d'accéder à la
plus haute marche du podium
il y aurait du coup fait l'histoire dans
l'histoire de la streak us en étant la
première femme triple joue en longboard
accéder à la première marche d'un podium
en catégorie open et pourtant ou
peut-être à cause de ça j'ai qu'une
envie c'est de me barrer en courant le
dialogue intérieur qui se passe à ce
moment là il est assez intense
j'ai un blocage vis-à-vis de la pression
c'est c'est vraiment ce rapport à à une
obligation d'être performante à un
moment donné qui va me faire perdre une
partie de mes moyens si je laisse cette
pression prendre le dessus et avec tout
le respect que j'ai pour les personnes
qui ont cette capacité à arriver à des
résultats incroyables au prix d'une
volonté de fer d'une discipline
incroyable et d'une résistance à la
pression sans faille
c'est quelque chose dans lequel je ne me
suis jamais retrouvé
j'ai toujours eu ce sentiment en fait de
me sentir comme une forme de fraude
parce que j'avais une forme de vision
binaire de la performance cette vision
binaire elles étaient soit tu es une
compétitrice hors pair qui est
complètement engagé discipline est
résistante à la pression capable d'avoir
un entraînement incroyable ou alors tu
es 7 dilettante complètement illégitime
qui
tina qui n'a pas son mot à dire s'il ya
bien une chose que j'ai appris avec le
temps c'est que la combler il n'y a rien
de binaire on n'a pas être dans une
catégorie ou dans l'autre et qu'on peut
atteindre performance et épanouissement
à travers bien des chemins
ces blocages je les ai compris comme
étant un héritage d'une forme
d'injonction culturelle et sociétale qui
associe le dépassement de soi et la
performance à une discipline spartiate
et à une attitude quasi combative
c'est du coup mon analyse et ça se
retrouve dans les expressions populaires
j'en ai pris quelques unes pour
illustrer mon propos être en compétition
avec soi même se faire violence ou alors
pléthore de citations dont celle ci
particulièrement édifiante de bruce lee
qui nous dit que celui qui veut réussir
doit apprendre à combattre à persévérer
et à souffrir je sais pas vous moi ça me
donne pas du tout envie d'être
performante selon ses termes et j'ai
appris en fait avec les années a nuancé
cette chose par contre j'ai voulu aller
un petit peu plus loin quand j'ai
commencé à faire cette recherche pour
vous trouver à la base uniquement des
citations je suis dit allons voir
l'étymologie du mot performance est là
c'est devenu vraiment très intéressant
figurez vous qu en ancien français
performance renvoie à la perfection en
train de s'accomplir
c'est par ailleurs un mot aux origines
anglo saxon qui vient du vocabulaire des
courses hippiques qui renvoie au
comportement du cheval pendant la course
ce sont les évolutions culturelles et
sociétales qui ont tout doucement fait
glisser cette notion vers une quête sans
fin d'un record toujours plus extrêmes
et on le voit également à travers les
synonymes qui sont associés dans le
dictionnaire tels que record exploit
prouesse on a donc une notion qui a
glissé avec le temps il s'avère que moi
et beaucoup d'autres gens qui ont
peut-être pas appris à l'articuler de la
même manière ne se retrouve pas dans
cette vision de la performance voire
même quand j'essaye trop de wurz et les
chaudes et de me faire violence
le résultat est carrément l'opposé de
celui que je voudrais avoir je me suis
rendu compte que finalement toute ma vie
que ce soit à travers mon parcours
sportif mais également mes études et ma
vie professionnelle j'ai toujours été
dans cette quête de la justesse de
l'expérience que j'étais en train de
vivre et c'est de cette manière que j'ai
connecté à une performance non seulement
juste pour moi
aligné avec qui je suis mais également
avec un résultat qui était tout à fait
favorable je distingue trois composantes
à cette notion de cette performance à
travers la justesse de l'expérience la
première c'est la connaissance de soi
ce que je veux dire par là c'est comment
vous vous autorisez à atteindre votre
plein potentiel en tirant parti de vos
talents naturels en priorité en les
cultivant plutôt que vous forcez par
défaut dans un moule qui ne vous
convient pas forcément même si à
première vue vos talents naturels
peuvent sembler comme des faiblesses au
regard d'une vision clichés d'un sport
telles que la stricte lui dire regardez
moi ou ou un poste un job
cette photo illustre très bien mon
propos comme vous pouvez le voir je suis
très aérodynamique
c'est parce que l'élégance et le style
sont des choses extrêmement importantes
pour moi quand j'ai débuté
j'ai commencé par apprendre à rouler
proprement et techniquement avant d'oser
aller vite à peu près l'absolu opposé
l'apprentissage choisie par la plupart
des riders qui fait qu'on a
régulièrement ou de danger public
sur la route le temps qu'ils assez
d'expérience pour 20 pour nuancer leur
manière d'approcher la luge
du coup cette propreté me rend très
aérodynamique et je compense me manque
de poids en prenant l'aspiration donc en
mettant derrière et en dépassant les
gens deuxième avantage de mon gabarit
j'ai besoin de beaucoup moins freinée en
entrée de virage parce que je risque
beaucoup moins de déraper du coup je
ressors en sortie de courbe avec
beaucoup de relances
troisième avantage complètement contre
intuitif l'a poussé au départ on pousse
comme des culs de jatte un peu
donc forcément j'ai pas forcément le
gabarit moyen de mes copains rider
autour de moi par contre une fan de yoga
et avant ça je faisais beaucoup de surf
du coup la technicité que c'est
pratiquement à porte et m'a permis très
naturellement de compenser mon manque de
puissance physique de force physique du
fait de mon gabarit quatrième avantage
je suis une princesse je déteste me
crasher vraiment ça m'agace au plus haut
point
du coup j ai mis à profit de manière
très naturelle
ma grande vitesse d'analysé de données
que m'offre mon joli cerveau pour
anticiper au maximum les situations
problématiques
ou alors avoir des réflexes très rapide
pour me sortir des situations
potentiellement dommageable pour mon
intégrité physique et le dernier c'est
que la canary de riz et l'amusement sont
des choses que je porte au niveau de
valeur et au delà de m'apporter un
bien-être sans nom c'est quelque chose
qui va décupler mon potentiel de manière
incroyable
donc finalement qu'est ce que j'ai fait
j'ai fait avec qui j'étais j'ai passé
des heures à analyser les courbes et à
regarder quelle était la money time
comme on appelle ça à la ligne à 100
millions de dollars qui va vous faire
passer tout le monde ou alors mon
matériel je les fais tous pleuré parce
que j'ai les mêmes roulement donc c'est
des petites gommes depuis dix ans alors
qu'ils en changent tous à chaque course
des roumains c'est la même marque même
si j'en ai régulièrement fin bref j'ai
juste découvert qu'en apprenant à me
faire confiance et en ne subissant pas
les pressions de l'extérieur sur une
vision potentiellement codifié pour
accéder à une certaine performance et
ben ça donnait des résultats vraiment
sympa
et finalement quand je me poussait un
peu trop parce que peut-être qu'en fait
ils ont raison et ben je me suis
retrouvé une fois à me crasher a senti
10 210 kilomètres parce que j'avais
changé mes gommes que j'ai pris du bobl
et que ça m'a fait maman volé je peux
vous dire que mon épaule elles le sont
encore donc très grosse leçon à cette
occasion là et il y a ça nous amène à la
deuxième composante la deuxième
composante c'est aussi important
que la conscience et la connaissance de
soi c'est la conscience et la
connaissance de son environnement
parce que votre environnement il peut
soit transcender votre potentiel
ou alors au contraire avoir un impact
très négatif à la fois sur votre
bien-être et sur votre performance
cette photo pour moi illustre
parfaitement un moment de magie absolue
alors pour vous ça vous parle pas
forcément mais en gros là on est à six
deux fronts en entrée d'un virage à 90°
droit donc angle droit
la route est fermée à la circulation
rassurez vous on arrive à 70 80 km/heure
et très clairement il n'y a pas vraiment
beaucoup de place à l'erreur
on est très concentrés s'assoit sur nos
virages visage par contre par ailleurs
on se connaît depuis des années on
s'apprécie on se respecte énormément et
plus important on fait confiance à notre
capacité mutuel a géré tout aléa qui
pourrait venir et ça c'est de l'or au
delà de ça il ya des gens qui ont un
très très gros niveau sur cette photo
donc ça crée une émulation positive
incroyable et l'ambiance générale de
l'événement était fantastique et il
faisait beau donc tous les voyants
étaient au vert je m'en souviens encore
même de ce virage de ce moment six ans
plus tard ah oui c'était pas une
compétition c'est un free ride ça aide
beaucoup aussi ma performance
individuelle nature était le résultat
d'une dynamique de groupe d'une
émulation positive de la part d'un
environnement qui était juste et qu'il
mettait non seulement sécurité en mode
challenge vient de manière positive en
temps de qualification le futur des
résultats assez moyens
par contre quand je me retrouve en phase
finale en poules de quatre c'est là que
j'ai un lapin j'ai des repères visuels
et là tout d'un coup la magie opère je
remettrai 3 3 aspects à cette notion
d'environnement tout d'abord il ya les
gens qui est autour de vous sur la ligne
de départ ou dans votre équipe vous avez
bien compris qu'on peut très facilement
faire le parallèle avec la vie
professionnelle qui est sur la ligne de
départ avec vous est-ce que je les
connais et ceux que je leur fais
confiance
comment je me sens ensuite le contexte
quelle est l'ambiance générale de
l'événement est ce que je ressens un
sentiment d'appartenance fort ou pas
troisième contexte quels sont les
risques à gérer encore une fois qu'ils
sont les gens autour de moi est-ce que
je les connais est ce que je sais que
leur comportement peut porter ciel moi
te risqué
quelle est la sécurisation de la route
comment je décide de me positionner
vis-à-vis de ça et ensuite à quoi
ressemble les bas côtés derrière les
sécurité est-ce que c'est du talus
verdoyant et accueillant ou est ce que
c'est un ravin avec 100 m de gaz ou tout
de suite bien ça peut être fatal de
passer de l'autre côté des protections
parce que l'environnement n'est pas
toujours idéal mais il ya deux choses on
a la responsabilité de connaître quelle
et l'environnement qui est bon pour nous
et d'ajuster notre comportement en
conséquence
ou alors d'ajuster les choses pour que
ce soit plus juste mais il ya des fois
où il faut composer également avec
l'environnement soit pas idéal soit
carrément toxiques et à ce moment là il
y a une chose très importante à prendre
en considération et ça nous amène à la
troisième composante c'est revenir au
coeur et au corps alors qu'est ce que
j'entends par là c'est revenir à
l'essence pourquoi vous êtes là pour
quoi j'ai commencé à faire ce sport en
premier lieu quels sont les émotions et
les sensations que je recherche
et surtout comment est ce que je peux
faire pour les connecter au regard des
circonstances
sur la ligne de départ quand je sens que
la pression passe complètement jeu que
je sens que je suis en train de mettre
dans cette situation où des fois sous le
stress j'arrive à me cracher tout seul
ça m'est arrivé deux ou trois fois
c'est très frustrant mais quand le temps
je suis en train de monter en pression
comme ça je ferme les yeux je me
souviens de pourquoi j'ai commencé ce
sport
à l'époque en 2003 quelles sont les
raisons qui ont fait que je suis venu
sur cet événement je remodèle tout le
discours dans ma tête est à ce moment-là
il le seul enjeu de vient de prendre le
plus de plaisir en me blessant pas parce
que souvenez vous je suis une princesse
et dans ce moment-là qu'est ce qui se
passe je me déconnecte complètement d'un
enjeu de passer au tour secours tour
suivant où de gagner la compétition je
lâche le contrôle je lâche le mental et
c'est là que la magie opère
parce que c'est dans ces moments là que
je vais me prendre au jeu que je vais me
souvenir dans quel point j'aime j'aime
m'amuser
et que je vais finir par dépasser tout
ou partie de mes chers compétiteurs avec
qui avait par ailleurs longuement
expliqué sur la ligne de départ à quel
point j'étais stressé et qu'ils allaient
quand même faire la course sans moi
parce que là c'est beaucoup de pression
moi donc des fois ça les agace des fois
ça les fait rire mais le résultat est le
même
moi ça me permet des charges et la
pression parce que le contrôle ça sans
intérêt la technique est là l'expérience
c'est capital la stratégie
on connaît tous les avantages que cela
peut avoir et bien entendu c'est
important de savoir se pousser un peu
mais la magie opère quand vous ajoutez
ce supplément d'âme quand vous autorisez
l'émotion et les sensations à revenir
quand tout d'un coup en faisant cela
vous ouvrez les portes en grand à ce
super pouvoirs qu'on a tous en nous qui
s'appelle l'intuition c'est l'intuition
qui va venir transcender l'expérience et
la technique
et c'est là que la magie elle opère
c'est là tout d'un coup je vais prendre
une coupe complètement improbable qui
sur le papier marchait pas mais qui va
me permettre de sortir devant tout le
monde ou que je vais légèrement décalé
enfin de schultz
quand on arrive dans le dernier virage
parce que oui un truc qui sont pas bons
et que quelques secondes plus tard ça se
crashe devant moi au freinage ba voila
bingo merci d'un tuyau ce que je veux
vous dire aujourd'hui messieurs dames
c'est que l'épanouissement l'expression
de soi et la performance pour prendre
des chemins que vous n'auriez pas
imaginer aujourd'hui je voudrais que
vous ouvriez vos perspectives sur les
différents moyens que vous avez pour
connecter à votre plein potentiel et à
votre performance
j'aimerais que vous autorisiez a ajouté
des cordes à votre arc a soigné le
processus autant que le résultat voire
même à y attacher encore plus
d'importance aujourd'hui je voudrais que
vous soyez performant et épanouie de la
plus belle manière qui soit en ayant
l'audace d'être vous en osant être vous
même et développer vos talents naturels
en osant soigner votre environnement
vous connecter à aux sensations au coeur
à l'intuition c'est votre droit le plus
absolu et j'irai plus loin c'est votre
devoir parce que personne ne le fera
pour vous parce que personne ne connaît
les réponses personne ne connaît la
recette de votre l'épanouissement de
votre plein potentiel
alors souvenez vous de ces moments
magiques dont je vous ai parlé en
introduction quels en étaient les
ingrédients je vous laisserai home
réappropriant pour un moment ce cher
paul verlaine et son art poétique et en
vous disant de la justesse et de
l'alignement avec soin avant toute chose
et tout le reste est littérature
merci
[Applaudissements]